hi I'm Ted balik with reason TV today
i'll be speaking with tom campbell he's
been a Stanford professor a California
state senator in US Congress maps now
Campbell is running to succeed Arnold
Schwarzenegger as governor of the
fiscally floundering Golden State let's
dive right in with the question about
just your general political outlook how
would you describe that less government
more freedom individual liberty and so
you're pretty comfortable using the l
word libertarian i feel very comfortable
with it i am a Republican I'm a proud
member of the Republican Party but I
have a lot of libertarian supporters and
what it fundamentally means is that you
believe that individuals should control
as much of their lives as possible and
that government should be restricted to
what is essential and otherwise leave
people alone what do you think of prop 8
I thought it was a mistake I think that
people should be allowed to marry what
it whether they're gay or straight I
believe in Liberty if you live in the
California long enough it seems like
it's an every year occurrence we're
perpetually in some budget crisis what
can we do to release ourselves from the
grip of this perpetual crisis what I
would favor is to go back to a system
that we had in California from roughly
1975-76 I think until nineteen
eighty-nine whereby by the Constitution
you couldn't spend more than the
previous year adjusted for inflation and
population and if the revenue came in
above that you'd send checks back to the
taxpayers that happened once governor
Deukmejian was governor and he actually
ordered rebate checks sent to California
taxpayers and then going a little bit
more creating a reserve fund so that if
you have a growth of revenue above let's
say the previous 10-year average it
would have to go into a reserve fund
aware it would our interest and then be
available for the downturn and lastly a
very simple but really really effective
program it take a few years however to
set up would be that you don't actually
spend this year's money you collect the
taxes in one year let it earn interest
and you then spend it the next year that
is to very beneficial effects one
is everyone knows how much money there
is to spend because right now you spend
what you think you're going to have and
everybody's optimistic you know I think
we're going to get out of this recession
immediately so let's not cut so much no
here's exactly how much money we have
and secondly when there's a downturn you
see it coming a year at a time you have
the political leaders in California
saying things like the budget has been
cut to the bone and that doesn't really
pass the laugh test I mean I'm sure
you're familiar with the California
performance review or they they outlined
you know it's a phone book thick
document showing here's how to eliminate
waste here's how to cut spending and yet
it's been practically ignored there's no
question about that or another way of
looking at it is if you compare us with
other states we were far above the
average on Medicaid we call it medi-cal
but for many years we had opted into
every additional medical procedure
because the federal government said
we'll pay fifty percent well that's good
from a fiscal point of view but you're
still stuck paying the other fifty
percent or welfare we were allowing
welfare to go without the work
requirements that the federal government
imposed as they are as their condition
far more leniently when it's discussed
what how did we get here some people say
they point to things like prop 13 is
prop 13 to blame absolutely not prop 13
provides a limitation on how much taxes
can go up and it a lot and it affords an
assurance for those employers we're
thinking about building a plan to
factory in a warehouse in the state of
California that they won't have the
value of that piece of property
reassessed as soon as they have sunk
their their their foundation as soon as
they poured their concrete it's the one
of the few attractions that I used to be
able to refer to as finance director of
the state to keep business to keep jobs
in California so when prompter teen went
into effect it did have the effect
immediately of limiting the amount of
revenue that was coming in from real
estate but we have now had 30 years and
almost every piece of property has
changed hands and so the lagging effect
has now been largely overcome Rahm
Emanuel famously said you should never
waste a good
crisis and for a lot of libertarian
types you know we rerun frightened when
we hear things like that remembering all
the things that politicians have done in
times of crisis but especially for
California politics is there it is this
a moment we can seize in seize on this
crisis in the opposite way that that
Emmanuel means so that we can really
come up with some innovative ways to
pare back government let me say that you
really have to be an optimist to believe
so but let's be optimistic this would be
the time to ask in every category do we
need government to do this could we rely
on private enterprise to do this what
about legalizing marijuana and taxing it
I think it's the wrong time to put that
forward in the wrong way to put that
forward you shouldn't be arguing that as
a financial solution because it suggests
that you're only doing it for the money
I think that it deserves very careful
attention very careful analysis of what
it would do to crime rate there's very
interesting evidence from Europe about
dropping crime rate rather than
increasing at dropping drug use rather
than increasing it if it's the right
thing to do we should do it whether it
brings revenue or not are there any
differences in terms of political
culture Sacramento versus washington DC
the fundamental difference which
pervades virtually everything fiscally
in Washington is that you can print
money you just increase the debt ceiling
print the money inflation will happen
sometime not not on my watch maybe I
mean that attitude believe me is
pervasive s proof I can give you is the
run-up in expenditures based on printed
money from last summer start with
President Bush so it's not purely
President Obama either with the 160
billion dollars of tax stimulus rebate
money which was going to get us out of
the recession seems so small and quaint
now doesn't acquaint is a good word then
we went to 350 billion under President
Bush and tarp money the first half of
the tarp and we got the second half of
the tarp money under President Obama and
we got 280 billion more for a further
bail out of freddie mac and fannie mae
then we got the 789 billion dollar
stimulus money I then we got the Federal
Reserve announcing that it was going to
spend one trillion dollars of printed
money to to recapitalize the banks well
you can only do that if you have the
printing press and what appears to be
the case and I and I hope I'm wrong but
appears to be the cases that we have
built up a tailwind for inflation which
will be a hurricane as soon as the
economy begins to recover and the
Federal Reserve Board says don't worry
we'll take the money out after exactly
the right time so it won't be
inflationary but think that through for
a minute how do you take the money out
of the system you tell banks not to land
you tell banks to increase their
interest rates you require higher
reserve requirements at banks in other
words you bring on the second recession
Milton Friedman was your PhD advisor at
the University of Chicago what was it
like studying under Milton Friedman oh
he was remarkable he was bigger than
life I even before he won the Nobel
Prize and when I was his student I
remember he had he resigned from
President Richard Nixon's Council of
Economic Advisers or or unofficial
counsel I think it might have been a
kitchen cabinet of economists because
President Nixon imposed wage and price
controls and that said a lot about him
you would have thought my gosh being
kitchen cabinet of the president being
bonded to Washington regularly I don't
want to give that up he did because he
was convinced President Nixon was
interfering with the free market in
imposing wage and price controls if
you're around today what would he say
about the current crisis I think he
would say don't just do something stand
there be careful about doing something
just for the sake of being perceived to
do something and that of course is what
the political environment conditions us
I'm going to be elected and do something
whereas it may be that the best thing to
do is to let the economy recover in in
the two years 10 months or faster that
it normally would and in this particular
case the doing something that would
trouble him
vinced is printing money so we're
showing that we are doing something but
we're running very serious risk
I